If this is your first time
joining us, welcome! Each week we help millions of
learners like you understand fast speaking English,
without getting lost, without missing the jokes,
and without needing subtitles. So why not join
our community of over 5 million learners
by hitting the subscribe button and bell
down below so you never miss
out on any of our new lessons.
Do you want to be able to understand native
speakers of all ages and in any situation?
Well, we will help you understand and speak English
more confidently and naturally with our free
3-part masterclass. Simply sign up now by clicking
up here or down in the description box below.
Now, let's do a quick quiz to see how much you've learned!
If you enjoyed this lesson then I definitely
recommend you continue your learning by watching
this lesson on our RealLife Englishchannel.